the bitcoin approaching its all-time
high values over the past few days
have fluctuated between sixteen thousand
five sixty and eighteen thousand four
sixty four it's not uncommon
for wide fluctuations to occur with the
value of bitcoin having gained nearly 70
percent this quarter
at the time of publication one bitcoin
is worth 17 000 418.
the all-time high meanwhile was re
recorded december 17 2017.
as of the morning of wednesday november
18 prices on the digital currency went
to 18
000 just a few hundred dollars short of
the all-time high which is nineteen
thousand
seven eighty three if you own
bitcoin let us know you own bitcoin and
if you own bitcoin
you're probably excited right now so why
do you think bitcoin is getting close to
its all-time high
so do you own any bitcoin i used stone
bitcoin you sold
i sold do you own it i don't know i
don't even know anything about it
to be honest i own some bitcoin okay um
back in
i don't know 2017 i threw down 25 gs on
bitcoin just you know buy and hold
strategy so now
you know when it plummeted over the last
few years like i wasn't gonna sell i
didn't need the cash i'm good
so i just sat let it see how it played
out
and i you know i'm happy i did we'll see
where it goes
now there's some people that say that
bitcoin is going to go down to zero and
crash and there's some people that think
it's going to go up to
a hundred thousand dollars but you know
what what you do know in investing if
you believe in the asset class
you buy and you hold long term where's
your 25 000 app now
uh in the 40-something range
okay all right so cool yeah so three
years you kept it it went all the way
down probably to eight thousand dollars
but yeah
yeah so uh good for you for having a
patience of buying hope but that's the
whole point with investing if you're
trying to get in and get out and get
rich quick like that's you shouldn't be
an investor be a j trader just go to
vegas and gamble but if you believe in
the asset i don't necessarily believe in
bitcoin or any of these little bit other
things i do believe that cryptocurrency
and blockchain is a real thing i don't
think that it's
nonsense or bs there are some legitimate
stuff and as we've seen
with our good friend robert kiyosaki who
came on recently
as they're printing more money and hyper
inflation
and um just printing money left and
right what's the term that i'm
the quantitative quantitative easing
there we go um and if there's so much
money that they're putting out there
then you put your money into little safe
harbors he said he's a big fan of silver
and gold and bitcoin so interesting
perspective so
think about it this way when when
products such as bitcoin
gold you know do well precious metals do
well what does it tell you
people why people are afraid people are
afraid when products like bitcoin
and gold do well people are afraid when
products like gold and precious metals
do well that means we are printing way
too much money
if biden becomes president and is no
longer president like he becomes
president
gold is going to go up because they're
going to keep printing money with
stimulus over and over and over again i
don't think they're going to get away
with the covet stuff anytime
soon the moment they stop printing money
and the economy is back open and people
are working you're gonna see the price
of bitcoin and you're gonna see the
price of gold go down
the moment that takes place right now
people are afraid
and bitcoin is a is a method of
protecting yourself
against anything that's going to happen
with the manipulation i mean i've had
some of these guys on a bitcoin world on
and uh i don't see it slowing down
anytime soon
i don't see bitcoin slowing down anytime
soon um question
you talking about you could time bitcoin
if you could time bitcoin
on the moment things open back up
bitcoin will go down
that's when you would sell it would so a
question for you now we've seen moderna
and we've seen pfizer 90
94.5 95. whether that's a cat and mouse
game or actually i just hope that it's
real
you talked about another stimulus point
i think there will be another stimulus
plan
that's gold stimulus is gonna help gold
precious metals and gold is gonna do all
the more money
but you said that there might be more
more stimulus but the more they print
the more gold so
in my opinion there'd be one more
stimulus and then hopefully there's
uh well places like new york and
california react
the way they do to covet and keep
schools shut down we're gonna need more
than one stimulus so let's just say
there's two stimulus let's say
biden's going to do two of them one in
uh january and let's just say he does
one in
july okay one injury if it passes let's
pass it no but he can still do an 800
billion dollar one 800 billion is still
plenty of money by the way if you print
billion these days 800 billion is
nothing you're kidding me unless you're
talking trillion dollars
a high roller like you put 25 000 in
bitcoin 800 billion is a lot of money
yeah
i've clearly joking here but one thing
to
my friends out there who are we i think
we would it would be fair to say we have
a lot of bitcoin enthusiasts that
probably follow our channel would you
say
yes okay here's my advice to my friends
out there
i put five percent of my asset into
bitcoin
five percent there's so many people i
talk to when i say oh
you have bitcoin hell yeah i got bitcoin
oh you have anything in the stock market
no way
do you have anything uh s p index fund
oh no i don't have anything with that
yeah you have any bonds no
nothing they're just 100 bitcoin that is
a recipe
for disaster so just quote me on that so
if you have some bitcoin cool respect
do not let that be your only investment
you could be in
very murky waters long-term if that's
all you have mercury waters